Bunt, unkonventionell und alternativ:
Das ist das Künstlerdorf Holzmarkt 25 –
mitten in Berlin, direkt an der Spree.
Rund 200 Kreative arbeiten hier,
darunter DJs, Künstler und Musiker.
Das kleine Stadtquartier hat
eine eigene Bäckerei, eine Kindertagesstätte,
eine Weinhandlung, eine Musikschule,
ein Restaurant und einen Club.
Natürlich wurde auch der Holzmarkt 25
von der Pandemie hart getroffen.
Seitdem steht hier vieles still, wie
Pressesprecher Konstantin Krex bedauert.
Man kann keine Kultur machen,
man kann keine Konzerte veranstalten.
Wir können kaum Leute bewirten.
Und das tut richtig weh.
Doch das kreative Projekt
lässt sich nicht unterkriegen.
Mattis Harpering betreibt auf dem Areal
eine Bio-Bäckerei.
Momentan hat er nur an vier Tagen
in der Woche geöffnet,
denn Besucher und Touristen
gibt es momentan nicht.
Dennoch bleibt er optimistisch.
[Wir] hatten uns sehr
auf diesen Tourismus verlassen.
Und dadurch hat uns das sehr getroffen.
Wir haben uns aber dann … Aus Not
mussten wir uns dann irgendwie umgucken
und sind jetzt ein bisschen ins Liefergeschäft
gekommen, was auch wieder positiv ist,
weil wir dadurch auch mehr
zur Bäckerei wurden
und mehr Brot dann auch produziert haben.
Mai 2017: Das genossenschaftliche
Vorzeigeprojekt wird feierlich eröffnet.
Von einer Pandemie ahnt damals
noch keiner etwas, und es wird kräftig,
eng an eng, bis spät in die Nacht gefeiert.
Schnell entwickelt sich der Holzmarkt 25
zum Besuchermagneten
und zieht Einheimische wie Touristen
gleichermaßen an.
Heute geht es auch im Studio 25
um einiges ruhiger zu.
Hannes Husten ist Sänger und Gitarrist
bei der Band SIND
und leitet das Tonstudio des Quartiers.
Er macht aus der Not eine Tugend – wie auch
der international bekannte DJ Oliver Koletzki.
Das war eigentlich für mich ’ne gute Pause,
mal nicht so viel auf Tour zu sein.
Und [ich] habe deswegen sehr viel Zeit
hier am Holzmarkt verbracht,
war fast täglich im Studio,
hab an neuen Projekten gearbeitet,
hab in dem letzten Jahr
ein ganzes neues Album geschrieben.
Und … ja, das hat mich persönlich
auch entschleunigt.
Der Holzmarkt war für uns als Studiobetreiber
und auch als Musiker am Holzmarkt
extrem wichtig, weil wir zum einen
durch die ganzen Streams
enger zusammengerückt sind
und zusammen Projekte aufgezogen haben
und neue Ideen entwickelt haben.
Und darüber hinaus ist der Holzmarkt,
wie gesagt, auch ’ne Familie,
die niemanden fallen lässt.
Das heißt, wenn mal die Miete nicht
gezahlt werden kann oder jemand
gerade anderweitig irgendwie nicht
klarkommt, ist immer jemand da,
der einem hilft.
Und man wird hier nicht sofort
rausgeschmissen oder fallen gelassen.
Kaum Kundschaft wegen der Corona-Krise:
Das macht sich auch im Geschäft
der Künstlerin Isabel Ott bemerkbar.
Denn ihre Upcycling-Kunstwerke aus Müll
kommen besonders bei Touristen sehr gut an.
Die Pandemie hat sie dennoch
als Inspirationsquelle genutzt.
Es gab ’n Thema für mich.
Also, während des ersten Lockdowns habe
ich meine Corona-Chroniken angefangen.
Das heißt, ich hab eigentlich jeden Tag
ein Piece gemacht, wo es um Corona ging.
Ich habe eine Kissenserie gemacht, aus ’ner
alten Stickbildersammlung, die ich habe.
Den Stuhl hab ich gemacht mit der Frau,
die einen Corona-Hut hat.
Toilettenpapier war ja auch
das Thema schlechthin.
Während Corona habe ich
diesen Halter gemacht.
Ich hatte immer was zu tun,
hatte immer Spaß dabei.
Ein paar Häuser weiter leitet
Jonathan Bucka eine Musikschule.
Zwar ist die Anzahl der Schüler
von 180 auf 150 gesunken,
der Unterricht findet aber immer noch statt –
wenn auch nur noch digital.
Im Vergleich zu anderen Branchen fühlen
wir uns hier natürlich privilegiert,
dass wir unser Angebot trotzdem
online weiterführen können,
weil viele unserer Lehrkräfte sind auch noch
neben dem Unterrichten als Musiker tätig,
in Orchestern, freischaffend.
Und diese Art der Einkunft ist natürlich aktuell
komplett weggebrochen seit März 2020.
Daher ist das immer noch so ’n letztes
Standbein, wo wir sehr dankbar dafür sind.
Natürlich gibt es auch
auf dem Holzmarkt 25 Verlierer.
Der Club Kater Blau bleibt vorerst
geschlossen und auch im Säälchen
finden schon seit Langem
keine Veranstaltungen statt.
Das Café, die Patisserie und das Restaurant
sind ebenso dicht.
Viele Projekte und Pläne liegen
derzeit erst einmal auf Eis.
Dennoch wurde bislang keinem
der Festangestellten im Team gekündigt.
Das ist die tolle Botschaft, die wir mitnehmen
können, dass unser Konzept
sich in dieser verdammt schweren Zeit
als tragfähig erwiesen hat
und dass man miteinander Wege
gefunden hat, da durchzukommen.
Zwar mit ’nem blauen Auge, aber wir stehen
noch und wir wissen: Es wird weitergehen.
Gemeinsam und solidarisch trotzt
das urbane Künstlerdorf der Krise
und ist sich sicher:
Es kommen auch wieder bessere Zeiten.